[Music]
so you haven't heard from me in a while
and there's some pretty good reasons for
that none of them are really actually
very good reasons for that but there are
some things that I would like to tell
you about that have been music about
quite a lot of my time
mostly eco geek ego geek is doing very
well right now unfortunately our one
remarkable employee Jamie was hired onto
a much bigger and better position and so
we have lost her and so I'm doing all
the stuff I used to do again and that is
a lot of work in addition I'm trying to
hire someone new and I'm doing very well
on that front by the way I think I may
have found someone thank goodness John
another thing going on right now is that
you you can't really tell this but what
I'm looking at right now is very
different from what I have been looking
after the last six months or so because
I am back with my old old camera hmm
such a good camera but you know you're
good you're good camera possible that
there are some people out there who
don't know this for a little while I was
recording some new segments for
Discovery's new green channel Planet
green and I had like a three-minute spot
sometimes on their nightly news show
where I would talk about clean
technology and solar panels and new
sustainably built cities and maglev
trains and underwater sports cars I
don't really know why the underwater
sports car fit in but it did I did a
second on their water sports cars so
anyway I was doing that and in order for
it to be television quality they sent me
this nice new camera and it wasn't mine
but I treated to like it was mine like I
completely discarded the old allure this
camera was under the couch I couldn't
even find it all of its parts were
missing the plug to make it plug in I
couldn't find that that was under a pile
stuff so my guess I'm not gonna be doing
that discovery stuff anymore actually
they said can you send us back the
camera and everything and I was like
yeah does that mean you're gonna stop
doing the thing where you send me money
and I send you videos and you put them
on TV it was like kind of like that deal
and they're like well don't assume
anything and I was like hey you're
making me send all the equipment back
like you you're making me put all of my
nice new equipment into a box and send
it to you via FedEx like that sounds to
me like I should assume something but
you know mm-hmm moving on to some good
news
Catherine
I'm thinking about buying a him but look
at my house we're very excited about
this one place and I really hope that we
are able to get in to it and then we
could show you around maybe you'll do a
little video tour of it to be awesome
what else did I want to talk about
yesterday my blog TV Chad you were
telling people that you thought that you
talk faster than me I don't think that
any nerdfighter thinks that is true I
think that everywhere in the world which
means that I faster than you that is
just one of the things that I can do
better than you there are things that
you can do but other than me but that's
not one of them so there was some
discussion about having a who can talk
faster on YouTube excluding Fresnel
contest I am totally in favor of having
that contest
additionally there are couple of project
things that I would like to talk about
first John it turns out that your book
Paper Towns is not going to be published
in the United Kingdom there are lots of
UK nerdfighters who are pretty angry
about that if you are one of them and
I'm serious only people from the UK are
allowed to do this please send an email
containing your name age and where you
live to publish John in the UK at
gmail.com now if I see enough emails
going to that address I'm pretty sure
that I can just send along and
information to that address to a bunch
of publishers in the UK and they can
just log in like I'll just I'll send
them the username and password and they
log in at Gmail and they will see this
huge list of emails from people already
to buy here town so if you want to put
in a little thing about how much you
want to buy here down and if you want to
send it to your friends I really don't
think that any publishing committing the
world could say no to a big list of
people who want to buy a book that they
could publish really easily it would say
no to that so if all you UK nerdfighters
can do that and I think that we can get
Paper Towns published in the UK pretty
quickly I would also like to share with
you right now
something pretty fantastically amazing
and it's going to make the video too
long but it's okay because this is
pretty much a separate video but this is
Paige Harwood K+ early award and Sarah
ryan performing pages arrangement of
Accio Deathly Hallows or string quartet
this is pretty awesome
[Music]
hi I'm Kate Slusser and I'm a junior at
Barry college and I fly the violet I'm
Sara Ward I'm a sophomore berry college
and I also play the violin
I'm Paige Harwood I no longer attend
Valley College and I play the viola I'm
Leah Ryan I am a senior at very college
and I play the cello